[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à l'école
élémentaire malmö den à mortain pour
parler du partenariat entre le centre
musique baroque de versailles et les
écoles scolaires de la ville voici le
sommaire le centre de musique baroque de
versailles s'associer à la ville de
maurepas pour promouvoir la musique et
le spectacle baroque nous avons assisté
à un atelier de chant dans l'école
élémentaire mal me donne à maurepas 23e
édition du festival jazz à toute heure
du 18 mars au 17 avril douze concerts
dans douze lieux différentes seront
proposées dans le sud yvelines et enfin
la ville des mureaux organise son
premier festival du film francophone
pour la jeunesse au programme ateliers
concours rencontre avec le parrain du
festival
[Musique]
je me trouve dans la cour de l'école
élémentaire mal me donne situe à
maurepas ici plusieurs classes
participent au projet d'action
culturelle établi entre la ville de
maurepas et le centre de musique baroque
de versailles
ce sont plusieurs établissements
scolaires de la commune qui vont
bénéficier d'un parcours artistique
complet pour découvrir le spectacle et
la musique baroque
margot elle allie bonjour bonjour vous
êtes la directrice du pôle actions
culturelles médiation et publics pour le
cmb vet'affaires c'est donc un projet
que l'on peut dire d'envergure un pur
laissé albert et comment vous avez eu
l'idée de faire un partenariat entre les
écoles de maurepas et alors le
partenariat entre maurepas et le centre
de musique baroque de versailles a été
initiée par la préfecture de région
ile-de-france dans le cadre de jumelage
culturel entre des établissements
culturels donc et les villes de la
région ile de france alors concrètement
comment ça se passe qu'est l'école sont
concernés me détailler un peu bien sûr
le dispositif que nous avons vu
aujourd'hui c'est celui qu'on appelle
les classes baroque qui sont des
parcours artistique pour les enfants
dans les écoles primaires et le collège
louis pergaud de maurepas c'est une
section artistique qui va naître en
septembre prochain au sein du collège et
donc ce que nous avons vu cette année
c'est la partie initiation mais ce
projet n'est pas simplement une casbah
rock mais bien une ville baroque comme
on entendrait presque une ville fleurie
ou une ville internet et donc nous
souhaitons proposer des ateliers aux
habitants de la ville et à tous les
services municipaux dans les classes
comment ça se passe concrètement c'est
des ateliers c'est ça ce sont des
ateliers de pratique effectivement avec
la chanteuse artistes eric grèce de ram
qui travaille pour le l'ensemble les
talents lyriques avec qui nous sommes en
partenariat cette année
les enfants vont bénéficier à la fois
d'ateliers de pratique de chant mais
aussi de théâtre de mise encore des
visites assister à des spectacles etc
etc il s'agit vraiment de leur proposer
un parcours complet autour des arbres
rock et bien nous nous avons pu assister
à un atelier de chant d'une classe de
cm2 à l'école mal me donne regarder
[Musique]
ouais
claire flambeau du monde chanson tirée
de l'opéra ballet les indes galantes du
compositeur jean philippe rameau ce
matin-là cette classe de cm2 a pour
objectif de chanter en choeur et sans
fausse note ce titre baroque
uni tous ensemble et puis j'aime bien
chanter et puis c'est amusant les petits
jeux kiev si au début on voit se
chauffer la fois on tourne et ensuite à
la fin on va chanter une chanson polaire
flocke du monde c'est bien je vais bien
le style le style de médiator c'est
j'aime bien la musique c'est très
relaxant je m'amuse bien et c'est drôle
et on travaillait très bien à vous le
centre de musique baroque de versailles
a lancé un partenariat avec la ville de
maurepas pour faire connaître aux plus
jeunes la musique baroque depuis
septembre ces élèves ont assisté à
quatre ateliers de chant mais aussi de
conscience du corps un parcours
artistique complet cette chanteuse
lyrique lille le court ce que c'est
vraiment un bon début je trouve que
qu'il ya beaucoup d'énergie qui a
beaucoup de plaisir à découvrir à leurs
voix ce que je trouve super à la danse
et qu'il découvre ça avec tout leur être
avec tout leur tout leur corps et il ya
une ouverture qui est formidable
beaucoup d'enfants ne connaissent pas
l'univers baroque le but pour le cmpv et
les écoles accompagner et former les
élèves à la diversité des genres
musicaux le baroque will pour la plupart
sont bien connus que ça leur fait des
prêts à rire de la musique autre que
celle qu'ils écoutent à la maison ou
entre copains et donc
ça permet aussi d'avoir des repères
repères dans la musique classique
qu'elle quel compositeur dans quel but
on écrivait tel ou tel morceau après
cette initiation les élèves qui
partiront au collège louis pergaud se
réuniront en section artistique dès la
5e au programme chants danses décors et
mise en scène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
margot l'aller comment vous avez
sélectionné les classes est ce que c'est
ce sont des élèves qui sont volontaires
alors les partenariats avec les
établissements scolaires sont décidés en
partie autour du quartier des friches
qui est le quartier au sein duquel le
collège louis pergaud et placé et donc
nous avons choisi des écoles primaires
en fonction de la carte scolaire pour
que justement les enfants puissent avoir
un parcours complète de l'école primaire
jusqu'à la fin du collège d'accord
hormis les classes baraka on appelle ça
comme ça les classes de laroque toute la
ville on vous l'avait un peu dimitri la
ville de maurepas est concerné vous avez
travaillé également alors avec
l'association maurepas entraide et les
services jeunesse et seniors pour
promouvoir la musique baroque comment ça
va se passer avec ces associations alors
nous sommes très impatients de voir
démarrer les ateliers avec les habitants
puisque c'est un autre challenge que
d'avoir des enfants dans une classe
nous allons proposer diverses activités
des ateliers effectivement avec les
services jeunesse de pratique peut être
un peu différente de ce qu'on a vu ce
matin pour leur faire aborder les choses
avec d'autres langues autour de la danse
du théâtre et cetera proposer pourquoi
pas des thés dansants pour les seniors
des visites de la ville de versailles et
alors tu combien de temps ça va durer ce
projet le projet ville baroque s'inscrit
dans le cadre du jumelage dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure et qui s'inscrit
pour l'instant sur une période de trois
ans mais c'est un projet que nous
souhaitons pérenne et je l'espère pour
de nombreuses années merci beaucoup
margot l'allier d'avoir été notre avis
penhars masia vous toujours en musique
le festival de jazz à toute heure
revient pour une 23e mission du 18 mars
au 17 avril le jazz mais pas que est à
l'honneur avec une programmation
éclectique dans toute la vallée du bouès
la 23e édition du festival jazz à toutes
heures a débuté le 18 mars rendez vous
incontournable du sud yvelines et du
nord essonne cette année le tempo est
donné par un cousin du jazz la tendance
de l'année lé autour du blues est une
musique très facile d'accès très
conviviale justement et est très varié
si vous aimez le blues joe kals avec
toute la puissance de la voix et des
émotions il faut aller couper case
hawkins un ken chanteuse irlandaise
assez incroyable ils vont
[Musique]
enfin si vous aimez le blues qui
déménage il faudra écouter superbe
non le chat
demain et
jusqu'au 17 avril jazz à toute heure ces
douze concerts sur douze lieux
différents par douze artistes différents
autrefois festival pur jazz il allie
aujourd'hui jazz blues chanson française
pop et même parfois du reggae parce que
c'est nos goûts voilà on aime toutes les
musiques et on a envie de les faire
partager quand on fait la programmation
d'un festival ont fait partager ses
passions fait surtout des préférences
pour les artistes c'est surtout des
coups de coeur pour les artistes ou
traction de l'événement la découverte de
nouveaux talents cette année l'une des
étoiles montantes vient tout droit de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique on parie
sur sa marâtre jeune artiste américaine
vers les etats unis le festival qui est
une chanteuse avec une voix absolument
incroyable à mon avis elle arrivera au
niveau de la fidh gérald et j'ai pas
l'habitude de dire ça
pour voir la prodige du jazz vocal
rendez vous le 16 avril à bullion le
reste de la programmation du festival
est à retrouver sur le site jazz à
twitter.com la ville des mureaux lance
son premier festival du film francophone
pour la jeunesse du 29 mars au 3 avril
des élections de film est proposé au
jeune public
au programme un concours de courts
métrages ou encore ateliers de doublage
de voix nous avons rencontré le parrain
de cette édition c'est un honneur c'est
un véritable honneur de voir son nom
ces photos des photos affichées mais
film la cinéaste au canada ecclésiaste
lemba est de retour sur ses terres
natales enfin de la ville des mureaux et
leur revient pour la projection de deux
de ses films le dernier un documentaire
voyage vers mes racines tournée en
république démocratique du congo d'où il
est originaire
[Musique]
c'est un documentaire que j'ai produit
donc sur mon premier voyage vers la
terre de mes ancêtres donc ce
documentaire sera projeté avec moi dans
mon deuxième film pardon je m'excuse en
deuxième film qui s'intitule loi comme
ton montréal ces deux films seront
projetés au cinéma frédéric dard le
vendredi 1er avril à 20 heures lors du
festival du film francophone pour la
jeunesse qui aura lieu du mardi 29 mars
au dimanche 3 avril aux mureaux et dont
ecclésiaste lemba et le parent se jouera
un plaisir de croiser des amis des
personnes qui me connaissent qu'ils me
voient la télé qui me voit dans les
films et qui me demande parfois comment
ça va si quand tu fais un fils aux
mureaux bon je suis incapable de dire
quand est ce que jeu tournera un film
aux mureaux mais en tout cas pourquoi
pas un jour au programme de cette
première édition une sélection de films
francophones venus du monde entier mais
aussi des ateliers l'atelier de doublage
de montage de tournage également un
concours de courts métrages pour les
jeunes des mureaux ouvert à tous donc je
pense que ce sera l'occasion de fêter le
septième art dans cette ville des
mureaux quoi c'est une ville dynamique
jeune le concours de courts métrages et
gratuit ouvert à tous et sans limite
d'âge samedi 2 avril à 20h45 l'ensemble
des courts métrages sera visible au
cinéma frédéric dard suivie d'une remise
de prix et c'est la fin de ce set 8
culture merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous la semaine prochaine dans un
autre lieu culturel yves et noir bonne
soirée sur télé 60
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]